we've already had many videos on
buddhism and its connections to hinduism
but what we want to do in this video is
more explicitly answer an important
question
why did buddhism emerge when and where
did and this is a question that you
should always be asking yourself as you
study history why did something emerge
why did something happen when and where
did and i encourage you to pause this
video and think about it maybe you're
reviewing some of the other videos on
buddhism and hinduism or doing some
research yourself
well let's remind ourselves of the
context
buddha emerges in northeast india and
modern day nepal at the end of the vedic
period hinduism has been evolving now
for many hundreds of years arguably
close to a thousand years now as we've
talked about in other videos there's a
spiritual core of hinduism described in
the upanishads this idea of atman your
inner self brahman the ultimate
reality that we live in an illusion of
maya and through meditation we should be
able to pierce that veil and eventually
break free from the cycle of birth and
rebirth samsara and become one with
brahman become one with the ultimate
reality but in the time of buddha there
were other aspects of hinduism that were
maybe even more associated with the
religion there is also a lot of ritual
in the vedas and in the time of buddha
the hinduism that he grows up in is very
focused on the ritual aspects of it and
it was a hinduism in which not just
anyone could do the rituals it was a
fairly stratified society that he grew
up in we've discussed the caste system
in some detail it's still a matter of
debate to what degree caste is
hereditary and it's actually part of the
religion but it was a fact of the
culture of the time
where at the top you had the brahmanas
who were the priests
and much of their power came from their
ability to interpret the vedas came from
their exclusive ability to practice the
rituals just right buddha came from a
ruling class he came from the
khashatriya class but even they were
considered one notch below the brahmins
and especially the bottom rungs of the
caste system these were fairly
marginalized people and so when buddha
emerges initially in a very privileged
life he's essentially a prince but
eventually when buddha sees the
suffering in the world a lot of the
suffering happening in these lower rungs
of society he looks for answers
spiritual answers and is not satisfied
by what he sees he's not satisfied by
the answers that he's getting from this
ruling class you could imagine that he's
even suspicious of it whether they're
focused on the true spiritual core or
whether they're focused on ritual as a
way to keep their power but there's also
another tradition in hinduism at the
time this is all very important to why
buddhism was able to emerge when it
happened
there was this tradition of asceticism
of people going off into the woods and
meditating and thinking about the nature
of life and these folks were much more
focused on this spiritual core and so
buddha initially takes that track he
goes and he meditates and he eventually
comes to realization he awakens so to
speak at the root of buddhism is that
there should not be the stratified
society that one should not focus on
ritual at the end of the day you need to
have a very personal path to nirvana to
escaping the cycle of samsara so i would
argue if i were to simply answer the
question why did buddhism emerge when
and where it did
well if you consider buddhism to be a
reformation of hinduism it's important
that buddha was hindu it's also
important that it needed to be reformed
or at least buddha thought it needed to
be reformed so it's important that at
the time that he lived hinduism had
become very ritualistic it had become
very stratified and he saw a need to
reform it now there's even a further
question
it emerged when it did and we have some
ideas of why that might have happened
but why did it become a major religion
one argument was that what he was
describing was just very compelling you
no longer have to go through this ruling
class through the priests anymore you
could have your own personal path
it was also perhaps compelling to people
who felt marginalized in the traditional
hierarchy of the time
another argument would be the emperor
ashoka who we study in other videos
that once he converts to buddhism after
feeling guilty for his war with kalinga
where tens of thousands if not hundreds
of thousands of people are killed
he converts to buddhism and becomes a
major patron of buddhism and sends
missionaries throughout the world to
spread it
so one argument of why buddhism spread
is that a few hundred years after buddha
you have a significant powerful emperor
converting to the religion and deciding
to spread it
now that leads us to a second question
are there other historical parallels to
what we have just described and this is
something that once again you should
always ask yourself in history
and what's the structure of this
well there's some spiritual core here
but eventually you have the ritualistic
side as it actually gets practiced
and you have a stratified society
where you have a class that has a bit of
a monopoly on the ritual derives a lot
of their power from that ritual
and then someone comes along and says
wait this priesthood is more focused on
power and on ritual than the true
spiritual core and they're not happy
with the answers that that priesthood is
delivering can you think of any other
parallels to that
well a few come to my mind and once
again these can all be debated and
that's the fun thing about history i
encourage you to debate all of these
things
about 500 years after the time of buddha
someone by the name of jesus of nazareth
comes on to the scene
where is the parallel well you have the
spiritual core of judaism that comes
from abraham and moses
but then you have the ritual of the
pharisees of the time they are the power
brokers he feels that the religion is
corrupted he sees the money changers in
the temple and much of his preaching is
a reformation a reminder of that
spiritual core
he also tries to encourage people to
have a more personal connection and
tries to break up the stratification and
once again you can imagine this to be a
very compelling message for those who
felt marginalized and the parallel goes
even further
just as buddha had ashoka come onto the
scene a few hundred years after buddha
to really popularize the religion
jesus has a parallel
roughly 300 years after the life of
jesus constantine is emperor of the
romans the same romans who have been
persecuting christians for 300 years now
of a sudden constantine not only allows
it to be legal but he eventually
promotes the religion and converts to
the religion and it eventually after
constantine's death becomes the official
religion of rome whether you're talking
about buddha or jesus you have a
reformer and then a few hundred years
later you have a powerful emperor who
adopts the religion and spreads it what
are other examples well even within the
world of christianity we could fast
forward another 1500 years from the time
of jesus and go to the time
of
martin luther
who at least from his perspective sees
the christian church in the early 16th
century and thinks that it is diverged
from the spiritual core from the
teachings of jesus that has become too
focused on ritual that the priesthood
and the papacy is really more about
power than it is about spirituality so
he brings about what will be known as
the protestant reformation which is
making the religion more personal not
having to go through priests having a
personal connection with the spiritual
core of religion
after this video think about other
historical parallels are there other
religions what about islam what about
sikhism how do they connect to these
ideas or how do they not connect to
these or maybe they're counter examples
and maybe there are parallels in history
that have nothing to do with religion
maybe it's more about politics or
science or economics
think about these questions